WOW.
WOW, WOW, WOW.
HAPPY TUESDAY, EVERYONE.
FIRST, WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE GREAT NEWS.
IT'S GREAT NEWS FOR YOU AND ME
AND ALL OF AMERICA, FRANKLY.
YES, LARRY KUDLOW'S BACK.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: YOU DIDN'T THINK WE
COULD DO IT BUT THERE YOU ARE.
MONTHS OF HARD WORK AND HOT
TUBBING BUT HE'S HERE.
I'M NOT PROUD OF SOME OF THE
THINGS I HAD TO DO IN THAT TUB
LARRY BUT I'LL DO WHAT IT TAKES.
ALSO SIDE NOTE AL QAEDA LEADER
AYMAN AL-ZAWAHIRI WAS KILLED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU'RE SICK.
WAS JUST 51 YEARS YOUNG, HIS
REMAINS WILL BE CREMATED AND
SPREAD OVER HIS ALREADY CREAM
ATED REMAINS.
AND TO THINK HE JUST FINISHED
PAYING OFF HIS WOMEN'S STUDIES
DEGREE.
WE WENT TO HIS FAMILY FOR
COMMENT.
THAT'S TERRIBLE, SHOW THE GUY
SOME RESPECT.
LET'S GO TO HIS REAL FAMILY.
YOU KNOW THAT'S EVEN WORSE.
YOU KNOW HOW THOSE GUYS HATE
PORK.
IT'S THE OTHER WHITE MEAT THEY
DESPISE.
NO WONDER HE BECAME A TERRORIST.
AT LEAST HE DIDN'T GET INTO
STRIPPING BECAUSE ONCE THE ROBE
COMES OFF IT'S JUST ANKLE SOCKS.
DON'T ASK ME HOW I KNOW.
SO WHEN I FIRST HEARD THE NEWS I
HAVE TO SAY I WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSED.
AND, NO, THAT'S NOT A QUOTE FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
FIRST, I HAD NOT HEARD THAT NAME
IN A WHILE BY CHRIS WALLACE.
BUT IT WAS A NAME I LITERALLY
HEARD OR WROTE ABOUT EVERY DAY
FOR A PERIOD OF YEARS AFTER
9/11.
BUT FOR SOME REASON, WE STOPPED
CARING ABOUT HIM.
AND ALSO STOPPED TALKING AS MUCH
ABOUT ISLAMIC TERRORIST
ESPECIALLY AFTER TRUMP GOT IN.
REMEMBER ISIS AND THOSE VIDEOS?
WE SHOULD.
SO WHEN NEWS BROKE ON THE FIVE
MY TERROR MUSCLES WERE NABY I
HADN'T USED THEM IN SO LONG
UNLIKE MY ACTUAL QUADS THAT WON
A BLUE RIBBON IN THAT WINE
FESTIVAL.
THANKS LARRY FOR TAKING ME.
BUT THE TERROR MUSCLES THEY WERE
RUSTY.
I IMAGINE IT'S HOW THE VIEW
PANELISTS FEEL ABOUT THEIR
BRAINS.
BUT I REALIZED I NEEDED TO GET
BACK IF INN SHAPE QUICK.
THE KILLING IS A HELPFUL
REMINDER THAT HAIR LIKE SMALLPOX
AND CHRIS CUOMO, NEVER REALLY
GOES AWAY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN 9/11 PLOTERS
HAVE ASSISTANCE LIKE THE
TALIBAN.
I HAD NO IDEA HE WAS IN
AFGHANISTAN HANGING WITH THE
TALIBAN, AND NOT IN A GOOD WAY
AT THE END OF A ROPE.
TURNS OUT HE WAS STAYING AT A
HOUSE APPARENTLY BELONGING TO
INTERIOR CONTRIBUTOR, AND NOT A
BAD PLACE TO DIE.
IT'S AMAZING WHAT YOU CAN GET
FROM AN AIRBNB.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK THE OWNER
WILL BE TOO HAPPY ABOUT THE
CONDITION THE GUESTS LEFT THE
PLACE IN.
THAT CLEANING BILL'S GOING TO
SUCCEED.
HOW TO GET BONE MATTER OUT OF
THE FORMICA?
I KNOW TOO SOON RIGHT?
TAKE A LOOK THE PLACE HAD A
BALCONY WITH GREAT VIEWS AND NOW
THANKS TO A MISSILE IT HAS AN
OPEN AIR KITCHEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BUT, BUT WITH 72
VIRGINS COOKING IN IT.
YEAH, HUH?
YOU'LL WISH YOU HAD DIED AND
GONE TO HEAVEN.
LET'S SHOW A PICTURE OF THE DEAD
GUY.
YEAH, THAT'S DEFINITELY AYMAN
AL-ZAWAHIRI, OR AS MERRICK
GARLAND CALLS HIM A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
IF YOU'LL NOTICE HIS RED HAT IS
UNDER THE TURBAN.
OF COURSE IT RAISES SOME
QUESTIONS.
IS AFGHANISTAN GOING BACK TO
BEING A BASE OF OPERATIONS FOR
TERRORISTS?
SEEMS SO.
WHICH MEANS J-LO AND BEN AFFLECK
AL QAEDA AND THE TALIBAN ARE
REYOUR NIGHT.
I FEEL SO BAD.
I'M NERVOUS WE WHACKED THIS GUY
AND MEANWHILE THANKS TO JOE'S
OPEN BORDER POLICIES THERE HAVE
BEEN REPORTS OF ANYWHERE FROM
FIFTY A HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST IN OUR
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
BUT STILL THIS IS GOOD NEWS WE
KILLED HIM BECAUSE IT MEANS WE
CAN PICK OFF THE PEOPLE WE MEAN
TO PICK OFF WITHOUT WAGING WARS
AND ANY DAY A TERRORIST DIES IS
A GOOD DAY IN MY BOOK.
OF COURSE WHEN YOU KILL A
TERRORIST ANOTHER TAKES ITS
PLACE.
YOU KNOW IN A WAY IT'S JUST LIKE
CANCELLED LATE NIGHT TALK SHOWS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TERRIBLE.
ONE FLOP AND THERE ARE THREE
WORST ONES WAITING IN THE WINGS.
YOU DIDN'T THINK I COULD MAKE
THAT ANALOGY BUT I DID, AND
THAT'S WHY I GET PAID THE BIG
BUCKS.
THOSE ARE SOME BIG BUCKS.
DON'T BE SO SAD, I'LL BE HOME
SOON FELLOWS.
THE FACE OF ACORN AND APPLES
FROM ME.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO CREDIT
BIDEN AFTER ALL HE SAID AL QAEDA
WAS NO THREAT IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WHAT INTEREST DO WE HAVE IN
AFGHANISTAN AT THIS POINT WITH
AL QAEDA GONE?
WE WENT TO AFGHANISTAN FOR THE
EXPRESS PURPOSE OF GETTING RID
OF AL QAEDA IN AFGHANISTAN AS
WELL AS, AS WELL AS GETTING
OSAMA BIN LADEN, AND WE DID.
>> Greg: SO LIKE MY AUNT, WHO
EATS PLASTIC ARMY MEN, BIDEN'S
CLAIMS HAVE NOT AGED WELL.
IT APPEARS AL QAEDA WAS THERE
AND WERE ACTIVE AND OUT IN THE
OPEN LIKE A COLD SORE ON A
SPRING BREAKER'S LEADERSHIP.
I HOPE IT WAS A COLD SORE NOT
MONKEYPOX.
BY THE WAY WHAT WAS I DOING WITH
HER.
AND I THINK WE CAN BE SKEPTICAL
ABOUT HOW MUCH BIDEN KNEW ABOUT
ANY OF THIS BECAUSE LIKE A RARE
MUSHROOM HE'S KEPT IN THE DARK
ON EVERYTHING BASICALLY LIVING
IN A NONSTOP BLACKOUT.
LIKE SON, LIKE FATHER.
FOR HIM EVERY DAY --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HOW DID THAT GET
APPLAUSE?
FOR HIM EVERY DAY STARTS OUT AS
A BLANK SLATE, SOMEONE COMES IN
AND ADDS THE DAILY SPECIALS.
I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS HIS
BRAINS ARE SCREAM SPINACH AND
CORN CHOWDER.
AND THIS GUY TOOK A VICTORY LAP
AFTER WE GOT BIN LADEN AFTER WE
TOOK HIM OUT.
THAT'S LIKE ME TAKING CREDIT FOR
TAYLOR SWIFT'S SUCCESS EVEN
THOUGH I HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT.
I MEAN TRUE WE DATED AND
EVERYTHING AND HER BIGGEST HIT
TAKE IT OFF WAS ABOUT MY
STUBBING MY TOE ON HER BED POST
BUT UNLIKE HER I'LL LEAVE THE
DIRTY LAUNDRY TO KAT'S OFFICE.
STILL WHEN BAD THINGS HAPPEN
UNDER A PRESIDENT, THEY GET THE
BLAME, AND WHEN GOOD THINGS
HAPPEN UNDER A PRESIDENT, THEY
GET THE CREDIT.
THE PROBLEM WITH JOE, HOWEVER,
IS HE WON'T TAKE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DISASTERS
SO IT'S HARD FOR ME TO GIVE HIM
A SLAP ON THE BACK OVER THIS.
BUT WHAT THE HELL, I WILL
ANYWAY.
NICE ONE, JOE.
BUT REALLY IT'S OUR AMERICAN
FORCES WHO GET THE ACCOLADES.
IT'S THE PLAYERS WHO WIN THE
WORLD SERIES, NOT THE MANAGER.
ESPECIALLY ONE WHO CAN'T FIND
HIS WAY OUT OF THE LOCKER ROOM.
SO JOB WELL DONE GUYS AND GALS.
YOU SENT A HELLISH MONSTER
STRAIGHT TO HELL IN TINY LITTLE
PACKAGES.
I WISH IT COULD HAVE BEEN
SOONER, BUT I SAY THAT ABOUT
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING 2024.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
HE PUTS THE FINE IN FINANCE,
HOST OF KUDLOW ON FOX BUSINESS,
SEXY LARRY KUDLOW!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE'S ONE BAD AS BROAD,
CAP FOR, HOSTS OF SONNIE'S
QUARTER ON SIRIUS XM, PATRIOT,
SONNIE JOHNSON!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SHE FOUND HER CAT IN A
DUMPSTER OR VICE VERSA.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND HIS JUMPING JACKS
REQUIRE SPECIAL CLEARANCE FROM
THE FAA MY MASSIVE SIDE KICK AND
THE NWA WORLD CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: LARRY THIS IS GOOD NEWS
WOULD YOU CARRY TO EXPAND ON
YOUR OWN PERSPECTIVE ON THIS?
>> Larry: I THOUGHT DID YOU A
VERY GOOD JOB.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Larry: REALLY DID A VERY GOOD
JOB AND WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET
9/11 AND HOW BAD THAT WAS AND
AYMAN AL-ZAWAHIRI WAS A KEY
PLANNER SO YOU'RE DEAD RIGHTS ON
ALL ACCOUNTS AND I'M GLAD THEY
GOT HIM.
NO HELL IS GOOD ENOUGH FOR THAT
SON OF A BITCH.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Larry: I WILL JUST SAY THAT
>> Larry: TIP OF THE HAT TO JOE
BIDEN, ESPECIALLY TIP OF THE HAT
TO THE INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
WHOSE REALLY ENGINEERED THIS AND
HAVING SAID THAT I'LL ISSUE A
WARNING BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED
IT.
THE FACT THE TALIBAN IS
HARBORING AL QAEDAS, THE SECOND
FACT IS, WE STILL HAVE NOT MADE
GOOD ON OUR AFGHANISTAN PROMISES
TO HELP ALL THOSE AMERICAN
FRIENDS AND ALLIES WHO ARE STILL
THERE STUCK IN THAT DES POT IC
COUNTRY AND ACTUALLY SOMETHING
MIKE POMPEO SAID ON MY SHOW,
AMERICANS SHOULD NOT GIVE ONE
NICKEL TO THIS REGIME THEY HATE
AMERICA AND ALL OUR VALUES SO
GOOD AYMAN AL-ZAWAHIRI IS GONE
BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR GUARD UP
ALL THE TIME BECAUSE THEY'RE
COMING AFTER US.
>> Greg: THAT LEADS ME TO
PROBABLY AN OBVIOUS FOLLOW-UP
QUESTION.
HOW DID MIKE POMPEO LOSE ALL
THAT WEIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: RIGHT?.
>> Larry: I HATE TO BE HIS
SPOKESPERSON, BUT I THINK HE ATE
LESS.
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: I HEAR THAT WORKS.
I HEAR THAT WORKS.
>> Larry: WASN'T THAT GOOD?
I JUST CAME UP WITH THAT.
>> Tyrus: YOU'RE DOING GOOD KID.
>> Larry: I WAS COMPLETELY
UNPREPARED.
IT WASN'T IN THE NOTES.
>> Greg: SONNIE, ALWAYS GREAT TO
SEE YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON ALL OF THIS?
>> Sonnie: I FEEL BAD LAUGHING
AT SOME OF YOUR JOKES IN THE
BEGINNING.
BUT I GUESS APPROPRIATE FOR
GREG, JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
IS MOST DANGEROUS ABOUT AYMAN
AL-ZAWAHIRI DYING IS IF YOU
LISTEN TO WHAT EVERYONE SAYS,
THEY SAY THE MAIN THING ABOUT
HIM IS HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
CONSULT OF PERSONALITY HALL BIN
LADEN HAD.
SO THAT'S WHAT SCARES ME MORE
THAN ANYTHING IS THE NEXT ONE
THAT COMES AFTER HIM WILL NOT
ONLY HAVE THE MURDEROUS IDEOLOGY
BUT ALSO THE PERSONALITY TO PUSH
IT AND I THINK THAT MIGHT BE A
REASON WHY WE HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
MUCH ABOUT IT IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
BUT IF THEY GET THE RIGHT FACE
AND THE RIGHT VOICE OUT THERE TO
BE IN LEADERSHIP OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, THEN I THINK WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, HEAR A LOT
MORE COMING OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT IN
TERMS OF OUR POLITICIANS HERE
PUSHED US INTO GLOBALISM
THINKING LIKE THIS WAS GOING TO
BE THE ANSWER TO WHAT AILS US
HERE IN AMERICA.
AND PART OF THAT WAS THE WAR ON
TERROR.
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS,
THE EAST ISN'T PARTICIPATING IN
OUR GLOBALISM.
AFRICA ISN'T PARTICIPATING IN
SOUTH AMERICA ISN'T
OUR GLOBALISM.
PARTICIPATING IN OUR GLOBALISM.
SOUTH AMERICA ISN'T
SO IT'S NOT GLOBALISM.
PARTICIPATING IN OUR GLOBALISM.
IT'S JUST WESTERNISM.
SO IT'S NOT GLOBALISM.
>> Greg: YEAH.
IT'S JUST WESTERNISM.
>> Sonnie: SHOUT-OUT TO HOTEP
>> Greg: YEAH.
JESUS FOR SAYING THAT ON MY
>> Sonnie: SHOUT-OUT TO HOTEP
SHOW.
JESUS FOR SAYING THAT ON MY
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW.
SHOW.
WE'RE TO THE POINT WHEREAS A
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW.
NATION WE ARE PUSHED TO
WE'RE TO THE POINT WHEREAS A
GLOBALIZATION AND WE'RE THE ONLY
NATION WE ARE PUSHED TO
KID AT THE BIRTHDAY PARTY.
GLOBALIZATION AND WE'RE THE ONLY
>> Greg: I KNOW THAT FEELING.
KID AT THE BIRTHDAY PARTY.
>> Sonnie: NOBODY ELSE IS
>> Greg: I KNOW THAT FEELING.
SHOWING UP.
>> Sonnie: NOBODY ELSE IS
YEAH.
SHOWING UP.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE VERY SAD
YEAH.
WHEN WE GO TO OPEN THE PRESENTS
AND IT'S GOING TO BE VERY SAD
AND WE REALIZE EXACTLY WHAT
WHEN WE GO TO OPEN THE PRESENTS
THERE IN TERMS OF LOST TREASURE,
AND WE REALIZE EXACTLY WHAT
IN TERMS OF LOST LIVES, IN TERMS
THERE IN TERMS OF LOST TREASURE,
OF LOST STATURE AROUND THE
IN TERMS OF LOST LIVES, IN TERMS
WORLD.
OF LOST STATURE AROUND THE
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
WORLD.
THEY WANT TO CALL US
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
ISOLATIONISTS FOR POINTING THAT
THEY WANT TO CALL US
OUT NO YOU GUYS DID A GREAT JOB
ISOLATIONISTS FOR POINTING THAT
MAKING US ISOLATIONISTS ON YOUR
OUT NO YOU GUYS DID A GREAT JOB
OWN.
MAKING US ISOLATIONISTS ON YOUR
>> Greg: GOOD POINT ESPECIALLY
OWN.
ABOUT THE ABSENCE DUE TO HIS
>> Greg: GOOD POINT ESPECIALLY
PERSONALITY.
ABOUT THE ABSENCE DUE TO HIS
KAT YOU'RE AN EXPERT AT GETTING
PERSONALITY.
BOMBED.
KAT YOU'RE AN EXPERT AT GETTING
>> Greg: APPARENTLY YOU'LL NEVER
BOMBED.
GET TIRED OF THAT.
>> Greg: APPARENTLY YOU'LL NEVER
>> Greg: I KNOW.
GET TIRED OF THAT.
IT GETS WORSE AS THE SHOW GOES
>> Greg: I KNOW.
ON KAT I WANT TO WARN YOU.
IT GETS WORSE AS THE SHOW GOES
AS A LIBERTARIAN ARE YOU OKAY
ON KAT I WANT TO WARN YOU.
WITH IT?
AS A LIBERTARIAN ARE YOU OKAY
>> Kat: OH, NO, I AM CERTAINLY
WITH IT?
NOT.
>> Kat: OH, NO, I AM CERTAINLY
THE TERRORISTS SHOULD LIVE.
NOT.
LIKE WHAT?
THE TERRORISTS SHOULD LIVE.
WHAT KIND OF QUESTION IS THAT?
LIKE WHAT?
OKAY, YEAH, I'M GLOWING TO BLOW
WHAT KIND OF QUESTION IS THAT?
YOUR MIND HERE.
OKAY, YEAH, I'M GLOWING TO BLOW
I THINK THE TERRORIST'S BAD,
YOUR MIND HERE.
9/11 WAS ALSO BAD.
I THINK THE TERRORIST'S BAD,
>> Greg: GOOD JOB
9/11 WAS ALSO BAD.
>> Kat: YOU TELL ME YOU DID 9/11
>> Greg: GOOD JOB
I'M GOING TO SAY NO, SIR, THAT
>> Kat: YOU TELL ME YOU DID 9/11
WAS NOT GOOD.
I'M GOING TO SAY NO, SIR, THAT
>> Greg: GOOD JOB
WAS NOT GOOD.
>> Kat: DID YOU EXPECT SOME KIND
>> Greg: GOOD JOB
OF NUANCED TAKE ON THIS?
>> Kat: DID YOU EXPECT SOME KIND
>> Greg: I WAS JUST THINKING IF
OF NUANCED TAKE ON THIS?
YOU HAD SOME, YOU KNOW, SOME
>> Greg: I WAS JUST THINKING IF
KIND OF COMPLEXITY HAVING TO DO
YOU HAD SOME, YOU KNOW, SOME
WITH, YOU KNOW, MISSILES AND
KIND OF COMPLEXITY HAVING TO DO
THINGS.
WITH, YOU KNOW, MISSILES AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
THINGS.
LIBERTARIANS THINK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
>> Kat: WELL, WE'RE NOT PRO
LIBERTARIANS THINK.
TERRORIST.
>> Kat: WELL, WE'RE NOT PRO
>> Greg: RIGHT.
TERRORIST.
THAT'S GOOD
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Kat: WELL, YOU LEARNED
THAT'S GOOD
SOMETHING NEW ABOUT ME TODAY.
>> Kat: WELL, YOU LEARNED
>> Greg: TYRUS ALL RIGHT WRAP IT
SOMETHING NEW ABOUT ME TODAY.
UP FOR US WITH YOUR
>> Greg: TYRUS ALL RIGHT WRAP IT
THOUGHTFUL --.
UP FOR US WITH YOUR
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW WHAT?
THOUGHTFUL --.
I'M GOING TO BE THE BAD GUY
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW WHAT?
HERE, I'LL BE THE KAT IN THIS
I'M GOING TO BE THE BAD GUY
SITUATION.
HERE, I'LL BE THE KAT IN THIS
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE POINT OF
SITUATION.
THIS.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE POINT OF
YOU SPIT IN THE FACE OF ALL THE
THIS.
ALLIES WE HAD IN AFGHANISTAN.
YOU SPIT IN THE FACE OF ALL THE
YOU LEFT THEM HANGING.
ALLIES WE HAD IN AFGHANISTAN.
YOU EMPOWERED THE BAD GUYS,
YOU LEFT THEM HANGING.
CHINA'S PUNKING US, RUSSIA'S
YOU EMPOWERED THE BAD GUYS,
PUNKING US AND YOU GO AND KILL
CHINA'S PUNKING US, RUSSIA'S
THE QUIET GUY THAT EVERYONE
PUNKING US AND YOU GO AND KILL
FORGOT ABOUT WHO WAS POWERLESS
THE QUIET GUY THAT EVERYONE
SO NOW YOU JUST INSPIRED
FORGOT ABOUT WHO WAS POWERLESS
EVERYONE WHO NEED AN EXCUSE.
SO NOW YOU JUST INSPIRED
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
EVERYONE WHO NEED AN EXCUSE.
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
NANCY PELOSI HAS TO FLY TO
ADMINISTRATION.
TAIWAN, I'M GOING, AND OUR
NANCY PELOSI HAS TO FLY TO
ADMINISTRATION'S LIKE I PROBABLY
TAIWAN, I'M GOING, AND OUR
GO, I DON'T KNOW.
ADMINISTRATION'S LIKE I PROBABLY
CHINA'S BIGGER THAN US.
GO, I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S OUR ADMINISTRATION.
CHINA'S BIGGER THAN US.
OUR PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, IF
THAT'S OUR ADMINISTRATION.
SOMEONE WOULD HAVE MADE A THREAT
OUR PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, IF
LIKE THAT TO PELOSI HE WOULD SAY
SOMEONE WOULD HAVE MADE A THREAT
EVERY PLANE I SEE WILL BE 500 OF
LIKE THAT TO PELOSI HE WOULD SAY
OURS.
EVERY PLANE I SEE WILL BE 500 OF
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A THREAT.
OURS.
NO ONE WOULD TALK TO US THAT
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A THREAT.
WAY, AFGHANISTAN WOULDN'T THINK
NO ONE WOULD TALK TO US THAT
ABOUT THE THINGS THEY HAVE A'
WAY, AFGHANISTAN WOULDN'T THINK
DONE BUT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
ABOUT THE THINGS THEY HAVE A'
THESE HORRIBLE MISTAKES BUT PISS
DONE BUT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
DOWN YOUR LEG IN AFGHANISTAN AND
THESE HORRIBLE MISTAKES BUT PISS
YOU GAVE THEM A MARTYR.
DOWN YOUR LEG IN AFGHANISTAN AND
I'M GLAD HE'S DEAD BUT THE
YOU GAVE THEM A MARTYR.
TIMING WAS PATHETIC AND IT WON'T
I'M GLAD HE'S DEAD BUT THE
TAKE OUR MIND OFF INFLATION OR
TIMING WAS PATHETIC AND IT WON'T
EDUCATION OR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TAKE OUR MIND OFF INFLATION OR
TO POLICE.
EDUCATION OR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NO ON SMOKE SCREEN IS GOING TO
TO POLICE.
WORK.
NO ON SMOKE SCREEN IS GOING TO
YOU KILLED AN UNEFFECTIVE GUY AT
WORK.
THE TOP AND NOW WE HAVE AN OPEN
YOU KILLED AN UNEFFECTIVE GUY AT
BORDER.
THE TOP AND NOW WE HAVE AN OPEN
WELL PLAYED.
BORDER.
>> Kat: YEAH.
WELL PLAYED.
STATISTICALLY SPEAKING, A LOT OF
>> Kat: YEAH.
THE TIMES YOU TAKE SOMEONE OUT
STATISTICALLY SPEAKING, A LOT OF
LIKE THAT, THE LOWER LEVEL
THE TIMES YOU TAKE SOMEONE OUT
PEOPLE WHO REPLACE THEM ARE EVEN
LIKE THAT, THE LOWER LEVEL
MORE RUTHLESS.
PEOPLE WHO REPLACE THEM ARE EVEN
>> Tyrus: BUT THE TIMING.
MORE RUTHLESS.
HAVEN'T CLOSED ONE DEAL YET.
>> Tyrus: BUT THE TIMING.
>> Greg: TO SONNIE'S